時はさかのぼり....
今から4年前
みなさん
2014年のYouTube
覚えてますか。
笑
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
あの〜、4年前なんですけども
UUUMのメンバーで
バーベキューしたんですよ
覚えてますか?!   4年前のUUUM
なんか今すごいUUUMって、
たくさん、(ウェッッホ)
今、UUUMって、すごいたくさん
クリエーターさんがいるんですけども
4年前って、もうほんと数えるくらいしか
Youtuberがいなかったんですけど
え〜、4年前に、そのバーベキューを
実はしたんですよ、みんなで
その4年前に集まったUUUMの初期メンのみんなで
今日は、
バーベキューすることになりましたっ！
ちょっとこのYouTube、
この4年ですごい変わったじゃないっすか
いろいろ変わったし、
変わんないこともあると思うですけれども
ちょっとね、この
4年経って
あの、UUUMの初期メンのみなさんは
どうなってんのか。
ちょっと気になるなって思って
ちょっとみなさんにお話とか聞いていこうと思います
UUUM初期メンバーの皆様、
お久しぶりでーす
(全)お久しぶりでーす笑
4年ぶりに再集結ということで
まあ、なんか、4年間いろいろ
あったと思うんですけど、
楽しく話し合えればいいなと思います
かんぱーい
(全)かんぱーい
(ヒ)多分、はじめしゃちょーと
(ヒ)ほぼ初めて会ったときだったんだよね、あれ
(カ)僕も初めて会った~
(め)私も初めてだった
(ヒ)ほとんど会ったことないくらいで
(ヒ)身長が高けぇ、とか動画で言ってて、
(ヒ)多分、1回、2回しか会ったことないんだな
(ヒ)さっき見てきたんだよ、4年前のやつを、一応
(は)マジですか
(セ)しっかりしてるね~
(ヒ)そうそうそう、そしたらなんか
(ヒ)想像以上に身長が高くて、
(ヒ)びっくりしたみたいな
(ヒ)こと言ってたから.....
(P)動画も結構控えている感じはあります
(カ)ダンテが?!
(カ)ダンテちょっと大人しくなったんじゃないの、最近
(は)いや〜、僕も大人しくなりましたよ、でも
(カ)えっ、はじめ君も?!
(カ)はじめ君の.....
(カ)でも、規模が大きくなったね
(P)去年で、いろいろと学んでいるし笑
(カ)いろいろ笑
(は)まあ、いろいろありましたね
(カ)ねぇー、いろいろ
(P)俺もすごい分かるんだよ
(は)分かるの?
(P)そう、だって俺だってあったし
(P)そう、だから、すごい気持ちが分かって
(カ)あ〜、そうか
(P)そう
(カ)あの集まる直前ぐらいね、
(カ)集まる前くらいね、4年前の
(P)だから、それで一緒にイギリスで会ったし
(は)あ、そっかそっか
(カ)あ、そっかそっか
(カ)いろいろあったね.......笑
(P)自分探しの旅に........
(は)わぁ〜
(カ)みんなちゃんと食べないと~
(P)はじめも食って、大きくなんないと
(カ)そうやで、食って、
(カ)大きくならんとあかんのやで
(は)肉食ったら、坊主っすもん
(P)坊主、狙ってるんしょ?!
(は)狙ってないよ笑
(は)どうですか、セイキンさん
(は)この4年間で、
(は)なんか変わったこととかありました?
(セ)変わったこと.....
(セ)変わったこと......
(セ)いや~、なんか別に特に変わってはいない
(は)変わってないっすか?!
(セ)うん、なんか別に気持ちは変わってないけどね
(は)あ〜、本当ですか
(セ)うん、心は小学生から変わってないんで
笑
(セ)なんていうか、あんま変わんないけど、
(セ)まあでも、なんか周りの環境は変わったかなと
(セ)という感じはしますね
(は)確かに
(セ)ねぇ、
(セ)YouTuberとしての立ち位置というか、
(は)大きくなりましたよね
(セ)そう、大きくなったし
(セ)事務所もね
(セ)４年前と比べたら
(セ)すごい大きくなって
(ヒ)焦げるかな？
(ヒ)う～ん、長いですね
(ヒ)一瞬だったね、とかはないね
(は)長かったですか
(ヒ)すっごい、長かったね
(は)確か、４年ですもんね
(ヒ)う～ん
(は)なんかこの、
(は)４年間のなかで
(は)親分の中で、
(ヒ)はい
(は)一番、変わったなあって思うことなんでした？
(ヒ)変わったなってこと？
(ヒ)すごい難しい質問なんだけど
笑
(ヒ)まず、変わらなかったことは
(ヒ)YouTuberでいられたことですかね
(ヒ)やっぱり
(は)う～ん
(ヒ)てか、ここで結構なんだろう
(ヒ)４年間、
(ヒ)みんな、あんま変わらず
(ヒ)こう、ブレずに
(ヒ)続けていられるというところが
(ヒ)案外、なんかサラッと
４年経っているかもしれないけど、
(ヒ)すごいくないっていう
(は)う～ん
(は)なんか、
(は)やめるYouTuberさんもいますもんね
(ヒ)いるいるいる
(ヒ)それで、でも、
(ヒ)みんなその
(ヒ)YouTuberでいるっていう
(ヒ)いれたっていう
(ヒ)そこは変わらないけど、
(ヒ)そのために、みんなすげぇ、実は
(ヒ)細かいところで、
(ヒ)いろんなことを
(ヒ)こう、変わってる
(は)う～ん
(ヒ)感じがしてますね
(ヒ)僕もそうですね
(ヒ)だから、あの～、やっぱ
(ヒ)YouTuberでいるっていう
(ヒ)変わらないために
(ヒ)編集を変えたり、
(は)うんうんうん
(ヒ)やることを変えたりして、
(ヒ)変化したから、今、
(ヒ)変わらずにいれるかなっていう
(ヒ)感じかな
(は)そうですね
(ヒ)で、なんかよく、
(ヒ)昔のはじめしゃちょーのほうが
(ヒ)よかったな～とか
(は)あるあるある
(ヒ)あるっしょ？！
(ヒ)で、で、変わっちまったな、
(ヒ)とか言われるでしょ笑
(ヒ)でも、変わってなかったら
(ヒ)たぶん、今もう、
(ヒ)YouTuberでいるか
(ヒ)分かんないからねっていう
(は)うんうんうん
(ヒ)ね？！
(は)楽しくないですもん、
(は)同じことしてても
(ヒ)そう、変えていかないと、
(ヒ)やっぱり
(ヒ)いろんな人も出てくるし
(は)めっちゃいいこと言いますね
(ヒ)変わりましょう
(ヒ)ね、しょうがない
(は)いや、本当にそのとおりだと思います
(ヒ)変わんなかったら、たぶんもう
(ヒ)退化していっちゃうからね
(カ)うわぁ～、うまそう
(は)Masuoさん、４年間で変わったことありましたか。
(Ｍ)変わったこと？！
(Ｍ)俺ね、いろんな経験をした笑
(は)いろんな経験したんですか。
(Ｍ)えっ、でも、はじめしゃちょーも
(Ｍ)いろんな経験したよね
(は)まあまあまあまあまあ
(は)良くも悪くも
(Ｍ)そう、あのねぇ
(Ｍ)いろんな経験して大人になった
(は)なりましたね
(Ｍ)そう、なん.......
(M)あの、たいていのことじゃ
(M)へと......
(M) へこたれなくなった
(は,M)う～ん
(M)だから、そういう意味で
(M)マジで、
(M)ポジティブな方向で、
(M)いい経験したなって思ってます
(M)そうそうそう
(は)結局は......
(め)結局は.......あっ、はい
(は)観ている皆さんに
(め)あっ、はい
(は)愛を伝えるためなんですよね～
(め)愛.....あなたの愛はなんですか。
(め)定義を、
(め)愛の定義を述べてください
(は)私の愛は......
(め)はいっ
(は)自分が楽しむことです
(め)笑
(め)自己愛ですか？！
(は)自己愛です
(は)はい
(J)はじめくんは
(J)僕が呼んだから入ったんだっけ？
(は)あっ、そうです、そうです
(J)笑
(は)あっ、そうです
(は)あの、UUUMに入ったきっかけ
(は)JETさんなんですよ
(J)そうだよね
(J)留学先から帰ってきたかなんかのときに
(は)いや、留学中に
(J)留学中にそっか、
(は)そうですね、あの～
(は)留学行ってて
(J)そうだよ
(は)UUUMができました、って
(は)日本で起きて
(は)で、やば、はぶられている～
(は)と思って、焦ってるなか、
(は)JETさんから連絡がきて、
(は)スカウトされて、
(J)そうだよね、で、
原宿で鎌田さんと一緒に飯行ったよね
(は)それで、JETさんのあの連絡で
(は)イギリスで救われたんすよ
(J)笑
(は)実は、イギリスの命の恩人なんです
(J)それが今や、トップユーチューバー.......
(は)いや～、そんなそんな
(A)なんか、昔よりも
(A)認知されているし
(A)あの、賑やかになっているよね
(は)うん、確かに
(A)もうちょっとさ、なんか
(A)まあ、言っちゃ悪いけど
(A)オタクみたいな感じもあったじゃない？！
(は)うーん、ありました、ありました
(A)なんかちょっと地味な感じで
(A)何、やってんの？！みたいな感じが
(A)最近、この４年間で
(A)もう、だい、
人気者とかが出てきて
(は)昔だったら、物壊してたんですけど、
(は)今、壊したら、炎上しますもん
(A)あっ、そうだよね、だから
(A)なんか、ねぇ、はじめくんの動画
(A)観てると、なんか、
(A)まあ、言っちゃっていいかのか分かんないけど
(A)炎上したやつとかも
(A)なんか、昔から観てると
(A)別に、そんな大して言うことなのかなと
(は)まあまあまあ
(A)思うくらい
(A)そうそうそう
(A)だから、それだけ
(A)みんなにあの、
(A)影響力があるっていうことだよね
(A)今のYouTubeはね
(は)そうですね
(レ)まあ、でも、再集結自体は４年ぶり
(レ)再集結は４年ぶりです
(は)元気でした？！
(レ)元気です
(は)元気ですか
(レ)まあ、相変わらず、僕は
(レ)おもちゃ
(は)おもちゃ
(レ)レビュー一本で撮って
(は)なんか、こう４年間で
(は)変わったこととかありました？
(レ)４年間で変わったこと？！
(レ)意外と、ないかな
(レ)やっている作品は、
(レ)僕はおもちゃレビューなんで
(レ)ひたすらおもちゃをレビューして、、、る
(レ)動画をアップしているから
(は)あ、それも変わらず？！
(レ)全然変わってなくて
(レ)久しぶりに会っても、
(レ)なんか、すぐにあの時の空気感に
(レ)戻れるというか、意外と
(は)あさひさん的に
(は)一番変わったなって思うことってなんですか。
(S)私自身の話というよりかは
(S)もう完全に女性YouTuberが
(S)増えたじゃん
(は)増えましたね
(S)だって、今日とかさ
(S)めぐみさんとあたし
(S)だけじゃん
(は)確かに、あのときも
(は)少なかったっすもんね
(S)そうそうそうそうそう
(は)でも、結局、
(は)その女性YouTuberが増えたのは
(は)たぶん、あさひさんが先導を切って、
(S)いや～
(は)道を開拓したからなんすよ
(S)どうなんだろうね
(は)あさひさん的に
(は)この４年間でなんか、
(は)変わんなかったことってありますか。
(S)でもやっぱ、
(S)この今日集まっている人たちってさ、
(S)再集結した
(S)初期メンバーとかはやっぱり、今でも
(S)先頭を切って、がんばっている感はあるよね
(は)がんばってますね、みんな
(は)はい、というわけで、みなさん
(は)おいしかったですか。
(全)おいしかったで～す
(は)で、今回、どうして、
(は)バーベキューをしたかといいますと
(は)えっと、
(は)というゲームがきっかけでございます
(は)なんと、
(は)２月の２２日にブレイブフロンティア２が
(は)リリースされるんですけども
(は)そのブレイブフロンティア２の
(は)テーマが
(は)はい、これです
(は)はい、というわけで、今回
(は)UUUMの初期メンバーみんなで、
(は)再集結してみましたっ
(は)で、ブレイブフロンティア２なんですけども、
(は)前作のブレイブフロンティアというのが
(は)あったんですけども
(は)それすごい、僕やってまして
(は)ダンテと動画もあったりしてて、
(は)すごい結構やりこんでたりしたんですけども
(は)それが更にパワーアップして、
(は)帰ってきたということで、
(は)今作も僕、
(は)楽しんでみようかなと思っております
(は)そして、なんと今回！！！
(は)特別なプレゼントがございます！！！
(は)この動画をみて、
(は)ブレイブフロンティア２をプレイしてくれた方から
(は)抽選で３名様に......
(は)この、
(は)初期メン全員の
(は)がプレゼントで～す
(は)UUUM初期メンバーのサインが
(は)全部書いてあるものってないらしいです
(は)このパーカーはもう世界に３枚しかないという
(は)激レアなパーカーでございます
(ヒ)古株ですよ、古株！
(は)はい、そしてこの再集結パーカーの
(は)応募方法なんですけども
(は)ブレイブフロンティア２の
(は)から応募できます
(は)みなさん、ぜひインストールして、
(は)応募してみてください！
(は)ブレイブフロンティア２のダウンロードは
(は）動画の概要欄からできまーす
(は)みなさん、ダウンロードして、
(は）遊んでみてくださーい
(は)4年間で、ちょっとみんな、いろいろ
(は)変わったりもしたと
(は)思うんですけども
(は)これからもみんなでYouTubeを
(は)盛り上げていきましょう!!!
(全)イェーーーーーーーイ!!!